the Syrian crisis is the story that's
been making all the headlines in Israel
for weeks public opinion here in
Jerusalem is split between those who
favor a diplomatic solution and those
calling for military intervention in
Syria anamanaguchi lube and I opposed
the way obama is handling the situation
jihad obey me his hesitancy will provoke
an even worse response in the future
devotion mmm Schliemann okay la Tasha
fishing Paloma this is a very serious
situation but I've never for a moment I
thought the solution would be a military
strike on Syria we meet them at sub I
think it would lead to an escalation Bam
Bam I myself even if they just vomit
once or twice on diplomat so I think a
diplomatic solution to remove the Syrian
chemical weapons would be more effective
amoeba suya llame o teri le long lines
have been forming a gas mask
distribution centers like this one in
Tel Aviv residents can come here to get
a gas mask or swap an old one for a new
one and even though many aren't overly
concerned they want to be ready for
whatever happens hello moon Douglas well
I'm not worried I have faith in the
strength of the Israeli army but I do
want to be prepared just like everyone
else here in Tel Aviv and Israel for
weeks Israeli media have been analyzing
a wide range of possible scenarios some
analysts welcome the proposal to place
Syria's chemical weapons under
international control that could prevent
them from falling into the hands of
Islamist extremists if we could see the
Russians taking a responsible role in
Syria taking out their chemical weapons
out of Syria and ending this crisis
without an American strike I think that
would be a good outcome and that would
set a great example for the Iranian case
as well although the threat of an
imminent US military strike has subsided
Israel will continue to watch Washington
its handling of the situation could
provide a new blueprint for dealing with
the nuclear threat from Iran